In today's video
We're going to be taking a look at how we built a propane based flamethrower that mounts to your arm and uses
electricity as an igniter
a
Few months ago grant told me about a video from a youtuber named
Darius of all where he made this whole big cool contraption that used propane and this whole
Tornado device he built to make a gun that shot like a tornado of spinning fire
It was a really really cool build and grant had the idea to try and build something similar but smaller that all fit on one
Arm, so if you like this type of build go check out his channel
He's got some really cool stuff and Jerry's of all, I promise I wasn't trying to steal your designs
We just happened to have a lot of the same and similar ideas
So there's some overlap but your super hero double flamethrower build not the same very cool
however
I'm now just going to show how I came about building this one and finishing it up to make it into a really cool
Fully functional flamethrower arm this is gonna be three parts today
We're gonna look at the build of the mechanics how I came about with the design that I have then in the next video
We'll look at fine-tuning and placing the parts in the right spot
And then finally, we'll look at making and decorating the housing for the unit
And of course if you haven't seen it already go check out our video where we test this thing out
But for today, we'll take a look at how to start putting things together. Let's get started
Here's what we're going for propane will flow down through a series of valves and tubes through a solenoid and out a nozzle
Will be ignited by the strong electric shock of being emitted from a Taser
We are trying to use propane as the fuel but what we want to do is get the propane out of this in a way
That we can burn it and not just like a little lighter style flame. We want like a flamethrower
Maybe not the same liquid stream that we get with the backpack flamethrower grant built
But something that really shoots out gets a flame at high speeds
So this hose this is designed to work
with these things and generally what you do is you attach it and then you have like a
Blowtorch or something like that that goes on the other end. It's good for a lot of different types of tools
let's take a look at how this normally works the nozzle for the propane tank has a little pin down inside that hole and you
May not be able to see it super well
But to get the propane out that pin has to be pressed this nozzle that fits on threads over has a rubber seal in it
that matches down right onto the bottle and so it doesn't leak anywhere and then there's a knob to control the flow coming out of
It currently it sets off
I can thread my propane tank on now at this point if I turn the nozzle propane will actually fill the hose, but the
Has another pin on the other side as a safety mechanism, so you aren't just venting propane into the air
So first step is I'm just gonna cut this end off of the hose now that I've disabled the valve
I'm gonna do something that's not very safe. And I'm just gonna show you that there is a propane flowing out of here
By blowing it right onto an open flame
You can see that propane lights on fire
we can see that propane is now flowing out this tube and we actually gonna want propane liquid not propane gas and the key to
That is basically turning this upside down but we've got so much tube that has some heat in it that it just keeps
Evaporating the propane so it still comes out as gas
What we need to do is modify the valve itself so that we have a much higher volume
Propane definite now that way even if it passes through some tube will still get liquid spring
So now we have a valve that just opens directly and it's just putting propane out immediately
and at this point I think if I turn upside down we can actually see some of the liquid propane and
That is what we want
More of this is dumping out just a little bit of propane at a time and we want a lot
Like a lot of propane so we're gonna take the direct route and we are just going to drill a hole
Straight through from one side out the other
We've now got a hole that goes right through this valve
Which would allow for just a massive amount of propane to be dumped out all at once. However
because of the way we've just
Modified this pin it no longer will come in contact with the pin inside the propane container
So there is another bit of modification we need to do and that's to add a cross piece
that goes from one side of this little pin to the other that's thin enough to still allow lots of propane through but is in
The middle so it will still hit that pin inside the propane cylinder
We've got our pin and we use two hacksaw to just cut a little notch down into it
This is a little scrap of copper pipe
We're gonna do is just cut a small piece off of this pipe that can fit down into that notch
And we're then going to solder it in place
We've got our little snippet of copper and it fits nicely into the notch that we've cut in the brass
We have maybe a little more than we need. So we'll try and cut that down a bit. So we have less extra
This basic design this using a piece of copper shim to plug up the drilled out valve
This is one of the things that I got from the Jarius of all channel now applying some flux. This is flux
that is normally meant for soldering copper pipes together and the two do not
Solder together quite as nicely as just copper and copper but I have had success
Melding these together with some solder
So there's a flux applied onto there the copper fit into place
And we've got our solder we're gonna try and heat this up to the point that it is nice and hot and add the solder
Onto the sides hopefully bonding that together without filling the inside channel too much
We got that little copper piece soldered on now. We want to clean it up using a file
So it's flush with the rest of the pin
While we're in modifying things
We also want to take off this knob and solder the peg on to the rest of the hardware the way that we've drilled things
Out can make it. So a little bit of gas can escape out that direction. We want to plug that hole up
So what we have is a little valve that automatically starts dumping propane as soon as it's attached to a cylinder
Now we're not trying to light the propane right as it comes out of our propane cylinder we want to direct it
So to do that we need to attach some kind of hose onto the end of this valve
Connecting into the back of this valve that we've created
we've got a
One-eighth inch - barb piece of hardware and this fits in pretty snug but we do want to make sure that no gas is leaking
Out so we got to use some thread tape fortunately. These small pieces often have tapered threads
So that even with the thicker thread tape, it'll go on pretty well. We do want it on there really nice and tight
It's got a stopped propane gas from leaking
The advantage of the barbed end is we can now add hose onto it and control how far it goes
We've got all this hose from the extender that we cut the valve off of earlier. That should fit onto this barb
There we go nice and snug
Now for the other end
I've got a piece that's a Barb and another barb on one side and this I'm kinda just gonna be using as a valve
So that is a good thing. We've got propane that sprays out the nozzle
We just have a very hard time controlling it so far
What we need is something that lets us turn the gas on and off
This is a 12-volt solenoid and here we have eight
One-and-a-half volt battery is giving us a total of 12 volts
So we should be able to connect the wires on the battery pack to the solenoid and have it open
The battery pack has a switch turn that on
And here that that is something inside the solenoid popping open when the solenoid is connected a small
Electromagnet pulls a small plunger against a small spring lots of small things going on at once and what it does
Is it move that plunger away from a seal so that when it's connected you can kind of even see it moving in there
We need to get the fuel from this nozzle into this nozzle to do that
We're going to use a series of more of these little brass fittings
first a threaded adapter
Then one that reduces down to a barb so it's kind of going to be mirror imaged and we're gonna be using this little barb
Because it perfectly fits onto the hose that came with the nozzle in the first place. We've got extra hose
We know it's designed for carrying propane
So we've already threaded that in let's add some more threads attach that to our solenoid and then the exact same thing on the other
side
Attach the hose on one barbed end
Feed that down to the solenoid following our arrow. This is the in
side and
Now in theory the solenoid is acting as a valve that will stop the propane from going out when we attach it to the tank
It's attached to the tank
I don't hear or smell any propane leaking out
Let's attach this to our battery pack and see if it suddenly lets out a burst of propane
Boom yes
Quite a bit. In fact, it seems
Alright one more thing. We're just gonna try turning this upside down and see what kind of spray we get. Oh
That is a lot of fuel dump it out at once we have propane spraying ethanol that's a little close to the solenoid
We're probably gonna want to add more hose on the front of that. So we have some control beyond the solenoid itself
Same thing when we open the valve all of our propane will blast out that little spot right there
The basic mechanics for how we're gonna get propane out of our tank is working now
What we need to do is light the propane we need a way to reliably ignite the spray as it's coming out of the nozzle
This is a personal defence taser
What we're gonna try and do is take this taser apart carefully
And what we want to do is take the leads out of the Taser and connect to the wires
That are currently connected to those leads. Well then use those wires to reroute somewhere else
So we don't have to have the teaser itself up inside the Jetta propane
But we'll be able to direct that arc right where we want it
All right, there's some extensions to my leads. And the other thing that I want to extend is the switch
I want to be able to activate this not at the Taser itself wherever that ends up in my arm, but in my hand
So now I need to connect to here and here everything else will just stay the same
All of the circuitry will work even the lights should end up still working
At this point we've redirected the leads of the Taser out front I've got some exposed wire
They're pretty close together. So it should be easy to arc and this right here should be the switch currently
It's set to OFF. So this isn't gonna do anything but once I set it on connecting these two wires should activate the Taser
Let's give this a test
little nervous
Hey, that's exactly what we want to see
Beautiful now we have electricity that should be intense enough to ignite some propane and I want to test that give it a shot
Yeah
That is that a result I'm hoping for and I'm calling that a successful proof-of-concept
We did not want to leave the flamethrower mounted to a chair using duct tape, obviously
So what we wanted to do was build a frame that would hold it all using some aluminum slats
Some rivets a couple of nylon washers and a little bit of webbing
This is what we came up with now
I haven't done the entire how-to exact step-by-step because this was very much
Just sort of figured out on the fly with a lot of trial and error
But we can show you the basics of how it was done and it's super simple
We've got one larger piece of the bar. This is our inch and a half wide bar. We've got a piece that I curved
I literally just bent this on the bench vise at this end
I drill the hole through this slat and this slat and I just used you. There's four nylon washers
Propane tank and strapped to this side right here
a
Handle can be added right here with
controls for what the electricity and the propane and this little plate is just something I added on as a place to attach our
Stun gun, so that's just gonna go right there. Then you can see I've got some straps there very very basic
They've got this one little knurled edge you fit the strap through here and it grips on they can't pull back
Against it unless you pop this back the idea. Is that it fits on about like this
Straps are holding on I can bend my arm
I don't even have to hold on to the handle stays attached mobility is decent not perfect
It does restrict my movement a little bit
But for the most part it holds on and I can bend my arm. I can move my arm
I can aim wherever I want. That's the goal
So things are coming along nicely
But we've still got a ways to go check back tomorrow to see how we finish up the insides and go check out the test
Video if you haven't already
Hey guys. Thanks for watching
If you're not a subscriber
Yet hit the bomb - get in the club if you missed our last video or you want to watch it again
Click up here at the top click down there if you want to see what the internet thinks you should watch next
That's it for now. Have fun. Be safe. See you tomorrow